we got to talk about some other looks
that were real game changers in fashion
Melissa you chose this 1997 Dior by John
Galliano dress on Nicole Kidman
um and that was well very different
first of all it was amazing number two
she was the first one in years since the
days of like Edith Head and that who
walked in in real Couture and that just
boofed the right the bar just went right
up because people aren't just having
samples and having them fitted to them
things are now being made for the actors
or the person yeah and it really shows
how a dress and a red carpet moment can
can make a career well and it doesn't
hurt to have Tom Cruise by the way it
also doesn't hurt to be well like your
client's 200 feet tall and gorgeous yeah
and you weigh nothing I guess it all
comes together all right Sharon Stone in
1998 Vera Wang Gap button up
this look has come back over and over
and over but this look she really said
this is okay and this look has been
recreated time and time and time again
you suddenly made it a very modern
version of it your version of it was
Zendaya I have to say is my favorite not
just because you're here because I
really believe that okay Christian thank
God you picked this share 1986.
I really just want everyone to go to the
Oscars like this at all times I agree
for the rest of my life yeah that's all
I want to see I want to go to that one
ball like that are you kidding me I want
to see headdresses at the grocery store
I want to see it all this is a moment
now and anyone else would look
ridiculous and Bob told me Cher actually
has everything she's ever worn really
yeah she kept everything I love you can
say Bob told me that's so cool that's an
archive I'd love to hang out in all
right this I thought was so interesting
because Rina Moreno wore her dress in
1962 where she won the Oscar for West
Side Story then she was nominated again
for the same movie and then she did it
again wore the same dress but in a
different fashioned on the top and I
thought
that's the real way to bookend I love it
oh yeah totally a legendary moment I
love that I think it's beautiful all
right let's uh you know some really go
Larger than Life on Oscar night right we
all remember those iconic looks let's
take a look at some of the instantly
iconic outfits to hit the red carpet I
cannot stop thinking about Celine Dion
creating quite a story in 1999
[Applause]
everybody was talking about that the
next day oh yeah yeah it was it was
hated but it has become one of the looks
that we will never forget it's been over
30 years and we are still we're talking
about it right now exactly iconic it was
how come no one has ever thought except
for like the band crisscross to wear
their stuff backwards I know and how
many gays did it take to convince her to
wear that you know what I mean a meeting
where they all got together and said
Celine trust us you look fabulous but
again unfortunately I wasn't able to be
one of those gays because I was too
young but the thing is also and a lot of
these looks that we're gonna see it's a
complete look and that makes a
difference and you can only be someone
who oh who the dress isn't wearing
they're wearing the dress very well and
that's very much seen now in lizzo she's
wearing the dress it's not wearing her
okay this one is also like um Cinderella
is going to the ball Gina Davis 1992
designed by Ruth Myers and Bill hargate
now bill hardgate was also a big costume
designer so like okay you love it give
it to us now I love Gina Davis she's
major she's like still really like sassy
in her age now and I love it okay it was
actually so bad it's so good so this is
not a dress that's made for what I say
real humans to wear okay I would I would
regret or be remiss as law said earlier
to not bring up my favorite the bjork's
fondant I have to I
and this look ruffled a lot of feathers
[Music]